I have a piece of gear for every member
of the Avengers oh these Black Widow
undergarments are really constricting
computer-generated characters and
comic-book movies look better every year
now if only they could get the voices
right I explain what I mean on this
week's episode of angry nerd first your
comments Vincent writes what did you
think of the Watchmen comic to movie
transition Vincent I thought it didn't
quite live up to the source material but
there were some great performances and
some brilliant sequences what did you
think let me know in the comments Alfred
Wong writes what's your favorite Marvel
robot Alfred that's easy
vision no wait no Nimrod no Jocasta
dragon man ah can't decide let me know
your picks in the comments I'll try to
nail down oh and thanks Alfred your
comment reminded me that I need to write
a poison pen letter dear Marvel the
sentient psychopathic robot Ultron is
one of my favorite comic book baddies
and I love the actor James Spader but
you should be banished to the negative
zone for combining those two things in
the flesh the CG version of Ultron in
the New Avengers movie has a fatal flaw
he's he sounds exactly like James Spader
anyone who reads comics knows that
Ultron is supposed to sound like an evil
automaton not like James Spader a it
sounds really
by your command imperious leader get the
humanoid get the end pruder okay okay
awesome sign I mean have you read the
comics
Ultron speech balloons had jagged edges
jagged edges hoary hosts of hog on how
much more obvious could they make it and
it's not just about the treatment of the
voice with vocoder effects it's also
about snagging and named celebrity this
casting decision is part of a larger
extremely lame trend of casting a list
actors as animated characters you need a
swaggering rooster on a farm hey let's
get Mel Gibson wisecracking shark let's
cast Will Smith that's out in voiceover
isn't the same as being in front of a
camera Peter Dinklage brilliant actor
but his voice over on destiny puts me to
sleep the hive haven't been on earth in
centuries that wizard came from the moon
if we aren't supporting full-time voice
actors how will we find a nurture the
next Mel Blanc June 4 a Billy West or
Cree summer if you don't know who any of
those people are I hate you forever but
I mostly hate celebs playing CGI roles
because I find it distracting when a
familiar voice comes out of a CG
characters mouth it pulls me out of the
story and it makes me think about the
actor the sight of Ultron and the latest
Avengers flick fills me with Glee but
the sound of him has me mentally ranking
brat Packers
in order of how successful their career
second acts of bed GD vs. Ringwald too
close to call now I could forgive Vin
Diesel as Group anyone who heard his
brilliant work on Iron Giant knows that
he's a voice actor at heart who just
happened to branch out into meatspace
performing Bradley Cooper is rocket
racoon over the line but I'll allow it
josh brolin Astana's just wrong and
James Spader Tron is the celeb voiceover
that broke the camel's back
no strings Marvel Robert California
should not be Ultron fix this now if you
hurry there's still time to get Frank
Welker to overdose oh you're still here
huh
Oh what was your favorite scene in the
original Avengers movie let me know in
the comments
mine was a shwarma scene I liked it
because it wasn't setting up the next
installment of the franchise and because
it was a blessed moment of downtime for
the audience as well as the Avengers
after an orgy of action and destruction
see one key appeal of super team comics
that the superhero movies have generally
shortchanged is these moments of respite
the Fantastic Four just hanging out in
the Baxter building before the signal
flare goes out or or mutants chillaxing
in the x-mansion before the Sentinels
spoil everything you get to see what
these characters are like when they
aren't saving the world the Marvel
movies X ice that they're like the
equivalent of a workplace TV series
where you only watch people work
Avengers 2 could be even worse with too
many characters too many bad guys and
too much expensive mayhem downtime is
important which reminds me I'm gonna
take some downtime for a while - I need
to dust my memorabilia before I pack it
up need to rebadge my comics and devise
some blistering new super-powerful rants
about Michael Bay let me know what you
think of Avengers 2 in the comments and
keep watching the classic old-school
angry nerd episodes while I'm on hiatus
hey you know to be funny we should get
some celebrity guests to overdub my
heartfelt farewell now I'll just
lip-synching and then you get Alec
Baldwin to say my lines or no way Jack
Nicholson get Jack Nicholson that'll be
even funnier bastards better not cheap
out on me like he did with my sidekick
Gary
okay
[Music]